ein Balkon in Kiev ein ausgebranntes
meerfamilienhaus es sind Bilder wie man
sie aktuell fast täglich in der Ukraine
sieht seit bald zwei Jahren sehen muss
dahinter stehen die Geschichten von
Menschen deren Leben durch russische
Raketen vernichtet werden soll das Land
wird seit dem Jahreswechsel von einer
der heftigsten Angriffswellen
erschüttert dabei entsteht das Foto von
Ludmilla opanasenko und ihrem Kater
toscher sie haben
überlebt ich war unter Schock
und das alles zu sehen hat mich
gebrochen es war sehr hart zu verstehen
dass das wirklich hier in unserem
Zeitalter passieren
kann in Ihrem Zuhause passiert in der
Wohnung in der die Ärztin seit 14 Jahren
wohnt ihr Mann volodomir auch Arzt war
gerade auf dem Weg zur Arbeit im Auto
vor der Tür als die Raketen auf ihre
Stadt flogen rannte er z
er kam nach oben ich lag im Bett und er
hat gesagt es ist zu laut komm schnell
ins Bad und er hat mich geschnappt und
wir sind ins
Bad eine Minute später ist es passiert
wäre er im Auto
geblieben und ich hier ich wäre
definitiv verletzt weil die Scheiben
lagen alle auf dem Bett auf dem ich
saß
es sind Sekunden manche nennen es
Schicksal andere Zufall die darüber
entscheiden ob ein Mensch hier überlebt
oder schwer verletzt wird es ist schwer
das zu
fassen ich hatte eine Vorstellung im
Kopf dass ich einfach die Tür hier
aufmachen würde und alles wäre okay als
wäre es nur eine Explosion irgendwo
gewesen vier Menschen sind in ihrem Haus
gestorben Russland zielt seit Tagen mit
unterschedlich Raketen und drohen auf
das ganze Land auf das Leben von
Zivilisten Millers leben ihre Wohnung
die sie verlassen die beiden Katzen
notdürftig im Koffer solch massive
Angriffe müssen lange geplant und
strategisch vorbereitet worden sein die
ukrainische Luftabwehr muss
Schwerstarbeit leisten alles aufbieten
was sie
hat natürlich ist es sehr schwierig aber
wir haben bestimmte Optionen und
Methoden um diese Raketen mit den
vorhanden Mel mit den Kräften die wir
heute haben
abzuschießen leider aber nicht genug und
deshalb brauchen wir eine deutliche
Steigerung der Lieferung von
luftabwehrsystemen und den Raketen
dafür so müssen zusätzlich mobile Teams
von Zivilisten ausrücken weil die
Luftabwehr nicht genug
Verteidigungssysteme hat um alles
abzufangen die mobilen Teams schießen
schlicht mit automatischen Gewehren doch
jede abgeschossene Drohne und Rakete
mensben diese hier haben Sie selbst vom
Himmel
geholt ich bin Leiter dieser kleinen
Einheit es sind unterschiedliche Leute
zwischen 24 und 59 Jahre alt aber keiner
ist langsam alle fahren raus bei
Alarm Kampf in der Luft und Kampf an der
Front hier trainieren Sie in der
hauptstad dafür
angrisbgade gemeldet haben sie gilt als
besonders beliebt und gut
organisiert der Weg ist frei
sch wir haben tatsächlich die niedrigste
Sterblichkeitsrate eine besonders gute
Planung in jedem Bereich im Angriff bei
der Verteidigung eine respektvolle
Beziehung sowohl zwischen den Soldaten
untereinander als auch zwischen den
Soldaten und dem
Kommandeur hier trainiert will sein
Schicksal selbst in die Hand nehmen
nicht darauf warten einfach eingezogen
zu werden in irgendeine Einheit eine
neue mobilisierungswelle droht die
Regierung hat deutlich gemacht sie
braucht mehr Männer für den Kampf Nazar
hat sich gemeldet gegen den Willen
seines Vaters der selbstsoldat ist und
Sorge hat um das Leben seines einzigen
Kindes er hatte Angst aber ständig hat
man neue raketeneinschläge und tote ich
konnte nicht nur zusehen und ich
beschloss dass ich die Sache selbst
anpacken muss denn nur Spenden werden
nicht
ausreichen auch Roman würde gerne der
Armee beitreten Angst vor Militärdienst
hat er anders als manch andere
nicht es gibt Dinge die wir einfach tun
müssen du bist ein Bürger was auch immer
kommt jeder Mensch hat seine eigenen
Pflichten seine eigenen moralischen
Grundsätze sein kein Richter jeder müsse
vor sich selbst verantworten ob er sich
zum Kampf meldet denn es gibt auch
Männer die sich verstecken aus Sorge vom
Militär auf der Straße aufgegriffen und
eingezogen zu werden so auch der Mann
den wir in Kiev treffen er kritisiert es
gäbe zu wenig Transparenz Soldaten
müssten ohne entsprechende Fähigkeiten
kämpfen er selbst habe zudem
gesundheitliche
Probleme dieses ganze militärische Thema
ist für mich sehr schwierig me
überzeug ich habe schon in der Schule
entschieden dass ich mich nicht an
militärischen Konflikten beteiligen
will eine Debatte über Mobilisierung
tägliche Angriffe die Ukraine steht
abermals vor riesengroßen
Herausforderungen und muss wieder auf
die Kraft und Resilienz ihres Volkes
hoffen die allermeisten auch lud Mill
openko und ihr Mann geben nicht
auf wir werden das Land nicht verlassen
ich persönlich will das nicht ich habe
ich hatte mein wundervolles Leben hier
ich habe es immer noch weil ich Gott sei
Dank überlebt
habe sie sagt sie wollen Ihre Wohnung
schnellst möglich wieder aufbauen und
ihrem Land helfen so gut sie das nur
können